a lot of charities are so localized a
goodwill is the big exception I really
like goodwill I enjoy donating stuff to
Goodwill for a couple reasons one is
it's convenient to is they have 2,700
donation locations yeah around around
the United States and they the in but I
understand people's aversion to it
because like well if I donate my clothes
they're gonna sell it and then how I
make sure those clothes get to people in
need well goodwill is still a charity
they take that money last year I think
they may 2.8 billion dollars 84% of
which is used for charitable giving that
non overhead related expenses that's
pretty phenomenal it's pretty awesome a
charity that uses a they're a United Way
I doubt it uses 84% of their revenue the
their donations to for charitable goods
and so they in fact let's put a link
there they're in the show notes to show
a lot of the good that goodwill does
without getting bogged down in the stats
of it the goodwill does a ton of good
now
now one thing Ryan today that that is
difficult that to get over so that will
they pay their CEO a lot of money
well apparently their CEO manages the
the company really well and they're able
to donate eighty four percent of the
revenue they make as a result isn't that
a good thing yeah it's never bothered me
that they make money off of a dude ever
it's never I've never even thought about
it until someone said something like oh
I don't do that because I'm giving them
something for free and then they're
selling it but it's like they have the
infrastructure they have the means and
it's not like they're trying to gouge
people with their prices I mean I don't
know if you've ever shopped at Goodwill
I know both of us have and like dude
they're not gouging for prices so I am
totally happy to give my goods to
someone who has the infrastructure to
redistribute those goods to people who
actually need them like I have that has
never bothered me now well I think that
if you're a woman and you have clothes
to donate maybe the best place is not to
donate to Goodwill because especially if
you have like professional clothes
there's a charity called Dress for
Success and what they do is they help
women who
our interviewing or they're they're
trying to they're trying to get
professional clothes and so though I
believe don't even pick it up for you
so Dress for Success we'll put a link to
that in the show notes and the last
thing I want to recommend because
charities are so the donation place that
are so hyper localized like I remember
back in Missoula we would go to a
donation warehouse and in fact they
would pick stuff up from you
in fact we bought some furniture from
them when we first met Missoula that's
how we learned about them and people
were donating their stuff and so we got
value from some of the things we bought
from them relatively inexpensively and
then they'll pick up your old mattresses
and stuff like that but you probably
don't have donation warehouse wherever
you live if you're listening to this
unless you're in Missoula but if you go
to donation town org that's how I found
donation warehouse you just type in your
zip code it'll tell you well here are
the three places in or near your zip
code that will come pick up and it's
very specific they'll pick up mattresses
this place will pick up toys this place
will pick up anything and so if you go
to donation town or you can find the
local charity for you or if that doesn't
help you out especially with things like
batteries those are hard to get rid of
you know especially if we live in
California it's illegal for us to throw
out batteries in the trash can Oh
Best Buy takes them here but and so does
target but wherever you are you can just
Google where do I don't or where do I
recycle batteries where where do i
donate blank in your local area and
you'll find like the the specific
charity to which you can donate you
these these excess things that you're
not able to sell
you